did Posner wrote an interesting article
on this and but it with
different thrust and he would argue that
when we provide philanthropy especially
in certain countries in which they are
failing democracies particularly when
we're providing food or medicines and
social services we are actually engaging
in a practice that will eventually hurt
those people because we're pacifying a
community that will be will be prevented
from engaging in the kind of reform
movements that would change that society
so he would argue that the more we give
philanthropy the more we give social
services we're actually preventing the
the society from engaging in reform
because they're modified in some way by
this do you subscribe to that so he's
arguing the charity diminish the
people's desire for improvement yes I
think that's BS I think people who are
hungry people who are need ought to be
helped immediately because the what what
this person is really saying is that I'm
going to do nothing and let children die
let people starve to death and hope
they'll get their conditions will become
so extreme that they'll rise up and
throw their tired away well of course by
the time that happens they'll all be did
I don't believe in that oh so in which
your final remarks what do you believe
in what what what are your parting
thoughts well I think all of us has a
responsibility to the people around us
in our community the town we live in the
city we live in the state or country we
live in the world in which we we all
have a responsibility to help other
people and we all may do it in very
different ways you may do it by becoming
a doctor you may do a by becoming a
lawyer you may do it by becoming a
social worker and so on and so on or you
may be the three of you in the back do
three entirely different things because
there are so many ways you can do these
things but you have a responsibility to
do something and if you become a doctor
doesn't mean you can't on the side do
something else if you call a lawyer
doesn't mean you can't on the outside
you something else you don't have to be
a doctor who helps people although we
hope you will be but you can be a doctor
who helps people and who also does this
that or the other thing of the other
thing because you have a responsibility
I believe to do that and I believe if
you do it not only will you have helped
other people and that's a wonderful
feeling you'll have but you'll feel so
good about yourself you'd be so happy
that you did these things well well
thank you thank you so much Julian I do
Thank You students it is so wonderful to
be inspired by julian bond here today
Julian I loved what you said as we
closed our program because we can all do
something we can all do something to
make the world a better place whether
we're an artist whether we're a doctor
whether we're a lawyer whether we're a
teacher whether we're a social worker so
the question for you is what are you
going to do to change the world